well my friends here we are they said
it would never happen me and trisha
making a podcast and uh
frankly i thought they were right for a
while
but let me explain first of all what how
what brings us to
here which is a pairing up very bizarre
i've been wanting to make a podcast with
like another comedian for a while and i
don't mean that
to compliment you i think i mean like
two big personalities
and in my mind when i kept trying to
think of people to do it with i always
thought you know me and trisha
have a really funny chemistry
oh yeah on all of your visits right well
yeah and i thought well you know [ __ ] it
let's just do it like that let's do a
live [ __ ] it
oh but this isn't live though no it's
just okay yeah no i
this is also take two so i feel very
nervous like i feel like i [ __ ] up
like we should take two no we did have
an intro already and now we're doing a
second intro because of technical
difficulties and i'm nervous because i
feel like i [ __ ] up the performance
you were nervous the first time
yeah that's what i'm saying i want to
make the same jokes you're restarting it
not that i made jokes i'm just saying
like it's just awkward now i'm like oh
did i say something
wrong like this podcast is a disaster
listen trisha why are you so stressed
we've done this before just relax
i think it's before i just always knew
like it was it out like it's just like
oh i'm never gonna see these people
again and it's like you know what i mean
like oh you have to see me every week
yeah because one of my questions for you
is how long do you think it's gonna last
because my thing is like
because with you i know that like you
your relationships are very hot and cold
and so we've built this whole set and
table
and i wonder you know i wonder how many
episodes we
we make before before this whole thing
is burned to the ground
no i think what's good about it is it's
like we're like the view you're like joy
behar and i'm like elizabeth hasselbeck
and even if they fight they still have
to do their job you know
i didn't understand that reference but
but i trust it's good
wait you don't know the view no i know
the view but i'm not familiar with all
the personalities but that's a good good
good
good
joy behar she so lived she would like
love her she's like an old liberation
liberal jewish what am i i love i love
libs
yeah you're liberal and jewish so that
so that informs everybody i'm supposed
to like
joy behar is like the like leader of the
liberal jewish people i generally don't
like jewish people does that surprise
you
no i'm kidding you always said that you
were so like proud joe
what's not like come on get out of here
i love jewish people
don't you find it odd to say i love
jewish people just as a general
statement
people do say that they think it's like
weird like i like fetishize or obsess
over jews but i just love them
what do you love about jews they're so
different
really do you find me to be different
well just jews in general like you guys
have such like
traditions you know like let's fast in
september
there's a lot of people that fast no but
like
you guys have like the new year's coming
up right so like this weekend's a new
year and it's like who just decides that
like it's so interesting you just decide
that the new year is
january 1st but jews are like september
you know the jews were doing
the new year before january 1st new year
yeah sure i don't know i don't know much
about it i just find them fascinating
okay yeah that's it you prefer uncertain
you prefer circumcised penis
i always get this confused i just don't
like the skin i don't know what that is
you like with no skin
that's what the jews have yeah we
invented that [ __ ]
really it's true yeah we invented that
[ __ ] okay
i love that you know there's a big
debate about um
people saying that it's circumcision is
uh
child uh abuse yeah that it's the
desecration of the of the penis i could
see that did you do your son or no
yes we did okay very jewish i thought
about not doing it to be totally honest
with you but
um we decided to do it because
first of all i think he should he'll be
super confused if his penis looks
different than mine
and aren't they going to see your penis
what that's normal you've seen your
dad's penis
everybody's seen their dad's penis you
haven't seen your dad no i don't even
see my dad shirtless i swear on my life
bible all that i feel like that's
weirder
than seeing your dad's penis is not even
seeing your dad shirtless
never go to the beach with your dad no
he's never had a shirt off swear on my
life asked my mom asking anybody never
seen my dad without a shirt
he's got something weird he's hiding
yeah like even when they had sex my mom
would like say he kept the shirt on
yeah but he's not fat he's very like in
shape he like walks
your dad [ __ ] with his shirt on i guess
back in the day i don't know i should
ask him about that and report back
not i don't talk to my dad about that
stuff wait is this a structured podcast
or we just talk no we're just talking
okay so it's not like like okay
i don't watch your podcast but i thought
you had like segments because you do
like highlights
i'm not doing segments so we're just
talking yeah dude that's what a podcast
is
what is it okay but hold on let's uh i
don't think they want to know about
circumcised penis like the first episode
like i feel like it's an intro like
hey i'm trish like okay hi well
everybody know okay this is what
everyone wants to hear about
since we've had you on we had yet again
another disastrous
episode of the bachelor season two
featuring you we all thought it ended in
disaster
but now you are dating my brother-in-law
why and how has this happened
the truth yes i want the truth
yo what the [ __ ] that was him not me i
literally mean should we start over
you want to start all up over what dude
look
do not i thought you put it on vibrate
do not disturb
okay is that confusing just just put on
vibrate
he's reading emails this is going to be
so boring we need to start over
okay we'll start over let's just get
right into
yeah we're starting no no no i'm kidding
i'm getting no please don't we're
starting over
keep the original intro and then put
this then put this part in no no we're
starting all over dan
for real no no no
no are you kidding
no okay keep this part keep this part
about us disgusting cutting
tell explain to me why you're dating my
brother-in-law nobody gives a
[ __ ] well obviously you do about
any of the [ __ ] you're talking about
other than that oh oh really
why are you dating my brother-in-law
can i tell you the truth like honestly
yes because like at first it was like i
just thought it was just like funny i
was like oh my god that's gonna be so
funny like i just like [ __ ] them and
then i'm coming back on the pockets like
ah i [ __ ] your brother
yeah and yeah that's it i mean that's
how it started for sure
so do you usually [ __ ] people out of
just to make a joke
yeah well no not always but like yeah
like sometimes to be like oh i [ __ ] this
person it's like funny
so mo so you [ __ ] moses for a joke but
then
you found out that he that he was much
more than a joke to you
mm-hmm yeah we're gonna be buying a
house together so it's a success
and you guys are so at first well you
know at first i was like
what's going on this is all making me
very uncomfortable because
i kept moses kept popping up in your
socials
and not telling us so i was like what
the [ __ ] going on i don't know why
that honestly i don't know why that i
was like why don't you just tell them
like
well that i agree with because he made
it way worse by not telling us
yeah because we like definitely were
like the first two weeks of quarantine
just
attached at the hip for sure and then he
had a traumatic event at his house so
then he just like
i'm like we should stay here forever and
that's what happened
um we've had like two like well it's not
really breakups but we've had like two
ish like times where we like stopped
talking to each other but we got them
back to each other so
yeah you guys had a couple blowups did
we how do you know he said it told you
yes okay you actually were the reason of
our first
breakup breakup we weren't dating but we
were yeah you made a [ __ ] you made this
hysterical video about how i was trying
to sabotage your relationship yeah
because in the thing you literally
we watch it together and i was like oh
my you're like oh yeah he said you said
he was applying as a goof and i was like
is that true you applied as a joke
yeah you just said you [ __ ] him as a
joke why are you offended
like that seems way worse he's like hey
i'm just going to apply as a joke but
then he's like oh i like her and you're
like i'm just going to [ __ ] him as a
joke despite them
i mean that's crazy yes so so how is it
that i
sabotaged your relationship because that
whole episode like you just were like
oh like i think he's embarrassed that he
likes her like it was supposed to be a
joke like
it was all the stuff i was thinking like
oh is he like playing me like you know
what i mean
so you ruined it at the beginning
well i blame moses for not telling us
what the [ __ ] was up because the whole
thing was weird and then well at the
same time he's gonna go on your social
media and then
like our fans see that so obviously we
have to address it
you think that you see it your social
media yeah it's all over our subreddit
and everything it's like
these these two these two guys making
like super cringy tick tocks
first of all they're not cringy they're
definitely not cringy but
oh my gosh really yeah they they don't
like your tick tocks either
where are they barking at go uh
anyone um um yeah first of all tic tacs
are good but
i get more insulted when they say that
we're the inverted
version of you and ela yeah
i think just because moses is like um
i guess they're both kind of like
understated maybe
or whatever that means it's quiet yeah
quieter well and everyone's quiet
compared to you to be honest
not you and they're skinny and i just
think we're like a little like chubbier
so that's the comparison
because we're like heavy and they're
like oh so you guys have a type
right well that's true um
let me so you guys have been dating
you guys are now living together i mean
what the [ __ ] is aren't you guys moving
a little fast well he has his museum
still he has a museum so he like goes
works there but yeah
every night we're together you guys
sleep together you guys are together
every night and he's moved [ __ ] into
your apartment
i mean he has like five shirts so yes
but all five shirts are at my house five
shirts
but now he hasn't and now you guys are
so we can like buy a house together like
a fancy one because he has like money
so it's the first person i have like
ever data that has like money and good
credit
how the i mean aren't you worried just
because your relationships generally
don't last very long buying a house
together seems like a drastic move
this is my like longest consistent how
long has it been it's only been a couple
months
six months six months today right yeah
six months a day
tomorrow tomorrow today oh
six months today you guys are so weird
moses is here by the way because he
brought her i could not come here by
myself you literally told me don't come
to my house she's never
on that episode you asked ela i think
this is like a poi for trish to come to
our house she knows she's not coming
it's not happening i was like
what a [ __ ] like i literally said that
she was just kidding i don't think so
yes she was no and that's what you were
like i'm gonna babysit
theodore yeah i was like keep her away
from our kid
but now she's like we could use a
babysitter or something no she didn't
did she she did say that she said that
and she sleeps through the night so i'm
like perfect we'll come watch him no no
no no oh oh
moses if moses comes yeah i find it very
odd that you're dating my brother
you still though like i think at this
point it's like well i've come to accept
it because
finally he opened up to me to the point
of being like i actually like her
and i like and that i think that we're
in a good relationship and this isn't
just
some weird thing he said i actually like
her
oh please don't take don't try to turn
this yeah i love he's alike
you are you gonna tr you're gonna turn
this into a thing
i can't wait to ask you questions i feel
like this is a podcast where we co-host
so i can
ask you questions about your
relationship because i feel like this is
like an interrogation
well this well this is just the thing
that happened that everybody wants to
know about
no he did not he said he said i don't
love her yet
but i really like i'm just kidding he
didn't say that
why you guys say you love each other
yeah of course
of course i mean we already like he
already is like we have to have a
wedding in israel too like we already
talked about oh my god
i was just talking about like maui we're
like let's get married to maui but he's
like but we also need an l.a because he
has a bunch of l.a like
friends and clients and then like he's
like but we have to go to israel because
that's where like his family
but then he said in israel they give you
money in the [ __ ]
tin and you like carry it and then you
have to get security and all that stuff
like that i'm like well let's just go
there if they're gonna just give us
money
yeah but they well dude what his mom is
gonna trip
does his mom know about you oh well this
is a point of contention which i'm glad
he's not in the room because
he refuses to post me on his instagram
because his mom looks at his story
and i was like because she's gonna trip
when she sees you and be like what the
[ __ ]
is that why
well i mean any well she's cons they
come from a conservative family
if you knew their their their dad is his
he didn't like you i knew that
yeah he didn't like me he thought i was
crazy i mean imagine imagine what they
like and you're like way crazier than i
am am i though because
i think so yeah
hmm interesting well why do you think he
doesn't post you on his story he told me
it's because of his mom
he said his mom looks at his stories and
he doesn't want her to know i'm like why
not
well how i just wonder how can he talk
about buying a house and
doing a wedding in israel and all this
[ __ ] and not posting on his story
because the mom stays with you because
of the baby so she won't even have to
see me i guess if she ever why is he
hiding you why is he ashamed of you
i trust his judgment really
if she yeah if people have a judgmental
family like you like i can tell already
by his sister and his brother-in-law
that i was like oh
he has a judgmental family yes my family
he's met all my family already my dad my
mom my sister like he's met everybody
and so
they love him we have family game nights
every sunday so i think i think
i think their mom would be nice though i
don't know why he's so
guarded about it i think it's fine
because i have his instagram on my phone
so i know if he's like damning people so
i know it's not about that so i really
do believe no no no he's
moses is not he's not gonna cheat on you
yeah that would never happen
right i check his dms every day still
oh my god girls are thirsty girls be
like oh hey sexy i'm like
and they do it because they know i'll
like flip you know what you mean like
they do it on purpose so dude you have
such a weird
world around you like there was a point
excuse me pardon me jesus excuse me
when you and moses were having a fight
there's like these all these super weird
underground instagram accounts trying to
expose moses
yeah with like three likes though which
i have to be honest with you trisha i
think you own those accounts
so did he he literally would be like
yeah i'm like but who
how could account how could an account
with like 10 followers
get a hold of moses's private dms i'll
tell you
and then post them and then how do you
find them i'll tell you later
tell me now i can't tell you now because
it's you
it's literally yeah um no i mean he
definitely had
the people he used to talk to are
psychos there are psychopaths that are
just like uber fans of
because we weren't dating right away
like the thing that's a little unfair
like you were like what are you guys
like we didn't know you can't just say
like we're dating after like a week of
meetings no i didn't even know that you
guys were
even like talking or hanging out yeah
but it was definitely just like hooking
up at the beginning for sure like i
was doing sex tapes with like you know
all these people and stuff like so it
wasn't like
officially official official until like
recently like a couple months
like a month or two ago yeah and that's
that's when i was forced to accept it
when it was official yeah against my
will
here i am i'm so excited for rosh
hashanah this weekend am i invited
uh oh no moses is invited
and he you want to bring moses you want
to bring trisha
no hesitation yeah i told him i'm like
you're not going unless i'm coming
oh my god i can't believe this no i
can't do this
i can't have trish at my rosh hashanah i
know hebrew now so i could say the
prayers i can do i can talk to your
family
this is so [ __ ] up that you're this is
insane
but i have to invite moses he's my
brother-in-law right
and now you're his significant other yes
this is so
[ __ ] up and i get to meet your dad and
i'm very excited too
now aren't you embarrassed that you were
saying you wanted to [ __ ] my dad
it's like a character like it's a joke
is it
just stop it's just you have to put a
limit on certain things
i have a boyfriend now as different as
single before i got a boyfriend
i have trauma about my dad because he's
such a creep
so you can't joke about [ __ ] my dad
oh okay well now that i know that i
know the boundaries yeah so you guys are
actually gonna come to our rosh hashanah
yeah
he'll come with me to the copenhagen
club every week so i was like come to me
to make
a test because then you guys are really
like crazy about it which i get
so we'll do coven covered in stds
together
i can't believe this is happening this
is crazy i'm so excited to come
i have a bunch of israeli shirts like he
knows i have all these hebrew shirts i
said shabbat shalom moses why don't you
post um
why don't you post on your stories oh i
told you i will
after these podcasts um
moses says moses said he will after this
podcast
oh establish some credibility he did say
that he's like
no i don't want her to know you on that
platform i need her to know that you
like work with them like okay
and why why is it that you think that
she needs to see that we work together
or why do you think that would help or
what are you afraid of your mom's
first impression i didn't want the first
impression to be
cause she well let's be let's be honest
let's be honest right
if she's like oh what's her name she
says what does she do for a living
she's an internet person yeah i think
but then she googles trisha paytas and
she sees you
[ __ ] you know shooting golf balls out
of your vagina or whatever goes on on
oily fans i don't think
sending vag pics to me on twitter
remember you did that but that was
before we were dating too like
yeah but still i'm just saying it
happened i want to do that now but
that's the kind of stuff she's going to
see
so that makes sense that moses would
want to tempt
her yes no that makes but
why he says he was protecting trump why
like
my family wouldn't judge you if you had
to dick on the internet like i don't
understand like what's there to judge
about that because i'm open with my body
yes you post nude on the internet i see
your ass all the time on my timeline and
i sent it to moses i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this
like if you don't like my vagina on your
timeline why can you post your ass on my
timeline
you're gonna compare my ass to your
[ __ ] yeah
um well i i'm i'm trying to hold back i
was going to say busted s vagina but i
don't mean that
i just trying to be funny everyone loves
mine my lips are in everything's tight
like
oh i was i was telling moses that you
know
as far as partners go you're
very successful very self-sufficient
i mean those are really good qualities
and then there's and then there's
everything else
but like those are two really good
qualities yeah i'm also really like
obsessive like i'm obsessed over him so
i feel like
that's not a good quality no you're like
that's a good thing because that means
you're like all about that person
like no i i just i think that's
i wouldn't want to [ __ ] anyone else like
you know that's when i know i'm in love
with somebody
like if i'm obsessed with somebody like
normally like but see like i don't find
it i don't i don't like that you're
going through his messages every night i
find that i find that possessive
well there's like a little issue like a
couple months ago before we were dating
and i was just like um
i just need to know for my own trust but
you know now that i have it i don't
really
i really don't look i think like the
first night i was like so excited and
now i'm like oh
like he literally doesn't respond and
it's just girls being thirsty
but that's it but they literally were
like catfishes because they like were my
haters i think it's like we think it's
one person that has these multiple
accounts whatever
it's like i know it's one well actually
there's definitely two but
and they're like weird obsessed fans and
it's fine whatever we
nipped in the bud okay good well
well someday you'll be my sister-in-law
it sounds like is that what it is like
maybe like sister-in-law in law right
sister-in-law and mom know you'd be my
sister-in-law no i don't think oh cause
it's like twice removed yeah it's like
i'm elo's sister-in-law
you're you're still my sister-in-law if
you marry my brother-in-law i mean i'll
take it i love the title sister-in-law
it would definitely be family definitely
both boning the same genes
oh like our babies will be oh our babies
would be related cousins
oh cute because they have the same
genetics skinny i thought you couldn't
have kids because you had double
gonorrhea or something
um yeah i mean i have a uterus still so
like i can still get like ivf or
something
go ahead tell me what were you going to
say moses was like still scared to come
inside because he thinks i'm like
lying but i mean sometimes we do but
it's not on the ovulation week it always
has to be like around
because he's like i believe i think it
could happen miracles i'm like all right
well then i guess pull out
whatever so you got chlamydia and then
you've got chlamydia on top of the
chlamydia what happened yeah i like let
it go for too long
oh that's so [ __ ] yeah i just never
get tested i'm literally so pain right
now i get tested like every week i'm
just like
what because i do like so what happens
if you let the chlamydia go wild
and like run its thing oh it like
damaged my like tubes so i had those hsg
tests which is like scarring in my tubes
and so like it's you can get them like
scraped off i guess like the little like
scarring of the tubes but like it still
goes through there was still some fluid
that goes through it so like
semen does still go through but i mean i
used to have like unprotected socks like
every day six times a day and i never
got pregnant for like years so i don't
know
so it's still like a possibility never
know if it's meant to be maybe but also
ivf and
all that stuff yeah
maybe i have an announcement soon oh
people were kept saying because we were
like we've got this big announcement
people kept saying that they thought you
were pregnant
yeah but i'll announce it here
you will yeah okay good and anything
else
yeah uh no anything i want all
announcements no just the baby i promise
but everything else no
okay uh what else dan how much time we
got
oh are you over it uh
i kept cutting but i think we're at like
35 35.
already yeah i'm over it no i'm kidding
no she's curious
this is so weird
do you let people know you have acid
acid reflux because it's like i know
now i'm like they say that coughing is
like the new n-word
oh cause corona yeah and so oh my god
do you get tested i feel like i'm a po
yeah of course so i'm like a public
hazard everyone thinks i'm like a freak
now
so what else is going on in your life
you're dating my brother-in-law that's
that's yeah that's exciting you're
killing it on only fans love my only
hands
you have a set can i see your 70 000
purse oh yeah
i was very proud this is the first time
i'm like wearing this out because we
never leave the house so i'm like let me
bring it to your bougie
family why why is this a seventy
thousand dollar purse it's one of a kind
pink um crocodile um shout out privy
porter so it's 100 authentic it's like
she's a handler for perkins specifically
so she
authenticates it and um oh yeah
oh this looks so good can i say and i
don't mean any offense but it does look
like a
70 goodwill purse definitely ugly i was
going to do a video being like i regret
this
i touch it yeah i guess yeah you have
clean hands
your hands are clean your hands are nice
well they said yeah thank you
your house is clean so i um what do you
think
i mean i i genuinely don't understand
how you can justify spending seventy
thousand dollars on that it looks dirty
i think it might have been used it
doesn't look as pink as the photos
even if you're trying to like flex like
i feel like people wouldn't even
recognize it it's not that distinguished
that's not true people will definitely
know like if you're into bags like if
you're like oh
because they know pink first of all
crocodile birkin's so hard anyways like
green they're always gonna be like 65
000
minimum as of 2020. i don't know why
you're watching this but 2020 they're um
that's the minimum but this is pink so
it's like extra
it's just extra and then also the size
it's 30.
it's 30 so like 30 is hard to find i
pick it up i just i'm very happy i want
to look around
it's not cute like it should have been
cuter it should have been pinker
it's cute though actually it kind of
matches this i guess um it just should
have been more of a
baby doll pink i don't get it
70 000. yeah i don't get it this was
this was
maybe a mistake but we still do it
because it's 70 000 so i can tell people
like look it's 70 000 because like you
have a fancy house and i have a fancy
bag so
yeah i guess and then and then you're
also flipping on me with the watch show
the watch
i don't know okay shout out are you
gonna come in here and flex on me that
hard a
a diamond i never wear rolex because i
got it during um quarantine so like we
really haven't gone out anywhere or
something
how much thought cost i got i don't we
don't know for sure because i got a
discount on
because i was like i got i gave a shout
out on instagram so i got like a
discount
i don't know was it like 28 000 i don't
know and how much should it have cost
i have no idea oh i'm so bad with like
can i feel it
is there any risk that the diamonds come
out or they're in there pretty good yeah
it's like also like a warranty or
something like that so
yeah i have another one coming that
one's like 50. are you afraid you're
going to get like mugged or something
when you're watching this
i don't want to flex it that's part of
the reason why i don't i don't wear
jewelry or care about stuff because i'm
just
you're just begging someone to mug you
yeah i don't like wear like every day i
just wear it for like special occasions
if i like just going to and from a place
you know so you brought that bag just to
come in here and flex on me no i just
never worn it out and i was like this is
my chance
because we don't go out oh rosh hashanah
i could bring a different one stop
bringing up russia's shauna dude
i'm very giving my ptsd and i haven't
even done it yet should i wear like an
israeli shirt
like a hebrew shirt what does that mean
i have so many of them
can you just wear can you can you just
wear like a full uh
he job can i just say i've been asking
moses to let me wear a hijab and he
won't let me he has a couple scarves and
he
won't let me wear it on public wait why
do you want to wear a hijab they're so
beautiful
we watched 90 fiance as in and
i want to wear that it looks so cool and
he's like no you can't wear it and i was
like why
why because it's the man's garment
and the women's so it's religious
it's disrespectful to the religion moses
says
it's kind of a fashion thing is it kind
of cultural appropriation to be like
i just want to wear a hijab because i
think it looks great and then people are
like
what is this crazy-ass cultural
appreciation
no i'm appreciating it like i think it's
beautiful like i think it's awesome what
do you just want to wear a full body
hijab not a full body i just want the
like one
around here on rosh hashanah can you
just wear a full body hijab
where the even the eyes are covered it's
just a netting they have those
yeah i'm gonna get that for you and and
4xl
actually can i just tell you your 2xl
teddy fresh is not that big it's very
triggering i ordered two xl t-shirts
mostly even know on the last thing we
did i had like my big shirt and it was
so
tight like the neck the body like
everything is like
this is a 2x and i buy 2xl from logan
paul i bite to excel merch from a lot of
people
and i'm like why is this one so small
like it's very triggering
i always buy 2xl to be really big and
comfy so i feel skinny and that one's
very fitted
the pink stripe one specifically well
our clothes are fitted but i guess
we don't accommodate like 50 g's
or whatever what size do you wear i wear
xl no why wh what do you think that i
wear
you're saying i wear a bigger size than
you yeah no this is an xl
right here okay skinny skinny you're
dieting why are you dieting
you already have a wife i have gerd i'm
gonna get diabetes
and i'm gonna die yeah i think i'll get
diabetes for sure
i don't want that [ __ ] so what i'm doing
is i stopped eating
dairy and bread and it's interesting
because
you really can't splurge that much when
you don't eat bread or
oh you're not eating dairy or bread yeah
when did you start this
uh just like a week ago oh you think
it'll like continue like keep it up
long-term i think
i'm trying i hope so because my mom is
allergic to dairy
and bread okay and i'm trying to get
control of my gerd which is the acid
reflux where i'm always coughing and
[ __ ]
oh it's a diet change that so you can
control it
i don't know if it's gonna work i do it
is better before i could not even talk
it was are you happier or do you feel
sad that you can't eat food you're like
i'm gonna die no it's f i
i'm so sad that i can't eat food i mean
i love
pizza and burgers it's literally gives
me it's one of the
one recipes of joy i have in this cruel
dis horrible
depressing world i just want to smash a
[ __ ] burger
and eat a pizza to my dome and i can't
do it you can't
and it's just it's just it's so sad
i can't do it yeah i go on a diet for
like a day and then but i could die
tomorrow so i might as well just eat the
food i want to eat
yeah but you're kind of in you're kind
of fulfilling the prophecy when you
yeah a pizza every day iconic though
like think of all the people that are
legendary died young
chris farley elvis marilyn anna
yeah i don't care about legacy or
anything that's all i care about
really you think you what are you doing
to ensure your legacy
just existing but i think in general if
i die young
it'll be more iconic think about there's
not to put that out there because i
really don't well you're gonna
i don't think you're gonna die young
from eating burgers
possibly that's my biggest fear though
is that i die have a heart attack and
they have all this evidence of me being
like a mukbang and being like see she
[ __ ] died of a heart attack
but i don't think that's how i go out
how do you think you'll die i don't want
to say i feel like that
is but you obviously have a you have a
premonition
yeah how is it how does it go no i don't
want to tell you like it's so sad and
tragic and like
does it involve drugs no oh no i wish
are you alone no
i don't want to talk about i don't know
why i'm scared i'm so scared about it to
be honest
but you've already thought it so what is
speaking it i'm gonna do speaking things
out there
it's like manifesting it i don't wanna
manage see i think that speaking it out
makes it not happen okay
i don't think so because anything i've
ever spoken out i've gotten
well anyway i'm scared to mention it but
anyways my point is i probably will die
young i've accepted this fate and i just
spend and live and eat and it's not
eating that kills me so
bring on the korean fried cheese you
know god that korean fried cheese i just
uh
it's just not fair i wish there was a
pill or i just want to
have diarrhea all the time or something
so i just you know what i mean like
it's just stupid it's really sad i ask
literally most every day like
do you just love being skinny like is it
just amazing like i can't imagine eating
whatever he eats everything and like is
so skinny
no guys like moses and ela they just
they're different they're different
breeding human beings
like i've spent a day with moses he's
just he doesn't get hungry like people
like me and you do
well now he does like he's gonna get fat
he's gonna get him
if he's gonna be with you he's gonna be
a fan he went to kfc and each got a
bucket of chicken and he like
took it down so you spent all day with
him but like how many meals does he eat
in a day
he doesn't need as much i thought i've
gained weight because i used to only do
like intermittent i told him literally
this week i'm like i can't eat dinner
with you because i have a music video
next week i have to like not eat dinner
like eat it before you come because
we will eat like three big meals like
one day we went to
dunkin donuts got breakfast sandwiches
and donuts then
for lunch we went to mcdonald's got
nuggets and he got a chicken sandwich
then what did we have for dinner that
day that oh we had boa steakhouse for
dinner with mac and cheese and mashed
potatoes
and then he sweets everyone so we always
have chocolate mousse cake and we always
have like
dessert every meal like oh let's have
ice cream let's have a look i could get
fat
but here's the thing i've eaten lunch
with moses so many times and
i'll like destroy let's say we go we go
out and we get shawarma
and french fries and stuff i destroyed
that [ __ ] and i moved on to
french fries and
falafel and he's got this is what ila
does too it's like
he only ate a quarter of his shawarma
and he only had three french fries
and in the meantime it's like you think
you're eating the same amount
but you're not oh okay that's what ila
does
that's really triggering that because i
feel like we always finish our food but
maybe i'm the one finishing it
he's he's just like matching your pace
but he's not eating
the same volume we order like five meals
for dinner like from like lalas we'll
have like empanadas
steak and we'll get two pastas no key
and all this like marinara pasta
mashed potatoes on the side he's just
being nice but he's not going he's not
doing what you're doing but then it's
all gone
yeah you ate it all you ate 80 of it
right moses
oh my god that's what ela does to me
like let's order a bunch of food and
then you just eat it well because eli
used to be like
we eat the same thing i don't know why
you're so fat i was like
wait what she said that to you for real
or no you're just like exactly no she
used to say that to me
and i'd be like girl i eat three times
faster than you and then i cl
and then i eat what you don't eat right
okay but the difference
is is she she's asking like why you why
are you so fat
moses is very appreciative of my body
i'm so fat i'm sorry you guys know it
turns me on so much your body
disgusting it makes me feel good because
i know i've gained weight i know i've
like gained probably a good 20 pounds
during quarantine like when our first
date i look at my facebook oh my god so
much thinner so i know i've gained
weight like i'm sorry i'm fat but i'm
going to lose weight
and then he's just like no your body is
perfect like and it's the difference
when i watch you guys on the podcast
is he feeding you is he a feeder i don't
think he's feeding
moses are you a feuder
i recall him telling me once before he
even thought about dating you that he
liked bigger girls i remember him making
a comment
i swear to god i swear he said he liked
heavier girls and it always stuck out to
me it's not heavy
triggered he was like i love huge girls
he's like i love
huge massive girls [ __ ] yeah you said
that
so i was like wow i know it's not true
i've seen girls like you say they're
always like skinny asians
so you're neither of those things
yeah i know he's like oh yeah i needed a
girl from thailand i did a girl from
korea i'm like what the hell like
and here i am i think moses has a real
trouble with
commitment though because he's not
really been in any long-term
relationship since i've known him which
has been a long time now
are you gay because that was like a long
time to go without girls
i think he's just a very uh independent
person
and i do think he likes to spite his
family which may explain you guys
oh i can see that for sure yeah i think
moses likes to
he likes despite his he's he's often his
whole life has
kind of been the pursuit of spiting and
distancing himself from his family i'll
take it i love it
yeah he's like i left it like right away
from israel i didn't go travel i just
[ __ ] left i was like bye i was like
okay cool
but yeah i could see that for sure i'll
take it it's fine whatever yeah whatever
whatever i think the same with him
though because i was telling like you're
not my type
either and i think it's like fun now
he's like a toy it's like oh i got a
middle eastern you know
oh my god it's fun i cannot [ __ ]
believe you're coming to rosh hashanah
dinner
this is so [ __ ] up you're gonna bring
her moses
yeah he said yeah coming he literally
said that he's like i'm not gonna go
he's very like that like any time we've
had a
coral or beef he's like i'm on your side
like thank you
you know he he's spoken about you very
nicely always even when you guys had a
fight and he's
like i don't know how much i can say of
what he told me without pissing you off
tell me i can say it all of it okay give
me permission
well he just said that well first of all
you were accusing him of like
[ __ ] like flirting with miners
okay can i just explain everything no
hold on you stop
let me explain what happened because the
people deserve to know
oh my god first you guys were dating and
then you started sending me all these
crazy dms with screenshot being like
your brother-in-law's [ __ ] crazy and
he's sick
and he's [ __ ] minors and i was like
all right and i was like i'll pull out
my phone and read the dna i did not say
miners i can pull out my you said
underage no
you want me to get my phone appropriate
age very young girls that are like 22.
that's what i said
yeah pull it out cause i even showed him
inappropriate age for him
he's like like that's not what you were
saying you were saying under 18.
i didn't say under 18. there's no way i
said that there is no way yeah
anyways do we really have to like go
this is so embarrassing
look the people deserve to know by the
way i unfollowed you on twitter because
you kept posting pictures of your vagina
i was like i can't handle this
yeah i did because moses asked you no no
okay i'll follow you on instagram too i
just can't handle your butthole vagina
on my timeline it's [ __ ] crazy you
were like offended when i was like
gaping i had like a gaping [ __ ]
because i had like a butt plug in there
and you're like why is it so big
what yeah that can be i remember that i
guess i blocked it out yeah it's
certainly not something i want to be
seeing on my timeline
so i hope you can understand okay you
ready that's not this is so triggering
ready i never said underage i know i
didn't
okay ready here we go dude i know we
don't talk but moses
is disgusting i have no intention of
making anything about this
but maybe check him talking to your fans
this
yeah i'm getting there okay this is from
a fat piece of [ __ ] fan of yours who was
23
and he [ __ ] on valentine's day he is
disgusting yeah 23. i said 23. yeah yeah
yeah hold on
first of all don't read this video you
better call this for real that is the
psycho
just don't well [ __ ] her then i don't
know but you got baited and then so
but my point is is that an actual psycho
okay fine who cares
well you have a card security yeah okay
but but anyway
you were sending me these dms and i was
like wow this shit's crazy and then i
actually
started hitting up moses because i was
like dude why i don't want i can't have
you flirting with my fans because you
were
i was a fan yeah i was a fan you said
there's audio
screen recordings check the bio and then
you're like check out this
exposed channel with 10 followers i was
like oh that's you
that's literally you oh you think i'm
the exposed channel yeah why would i
want to like embarrass myself
no you were just it was all about trying
to expose why when i was like
like really truly like in love with him
why would i try to like kick him you
said he talked so much trash about me
and made fun of my body and then used me
he's scary and vile
needs help yes i was really mad man but
that's the difference
i didn't answer because i was like moses
what is going on and then you say bonded
a month later you're really trying to
charge it because that was because i
because you yeah because i didn't want
to this was insane to shoot yourself
we were fine because we had fathers and
everything and you're like well i
because
i'm like i have to address the issue
that tristan just well let me finish
this
can we not he said just so you know none
of this was a troll
i truly thought he liked me but he
played me he always was bitter he was
never on your
oh here i won't read this i won't read
that yeah that's fine oh my god look at
me just stop all together please this
was already a point of contention we're
past it just stop
yeah here you said he talks to underage
girls
no right there he talks to underage
girls
weird where i literally don't see right
there he talks to underage girls
confirmed that he thinks about what that
was yes but but this is a difference
no it's not it's the same set of
messages about his work stop it's the
same set of messages
five seven ten thirty five seven ten
thirty telling you this is
this girl you said read this part he
said it says
he talks to underage girls it's separate
it's a period it's not
it's look it's 5 7 10 30 p.m 5 7 10 30
p.m
can i just say he doesn't talk to
anybody now not even about his work not
men not women so i'm just trying to
explain the situation
well i saved him from further
embarrassment he says he stalks to
underage girls i don't expect a response
and again
i don't want to talk to you again but
he's just a fraud and he's scary
okay can i not put this in there this is
going to be so bad oh they're in a toxic
relationship
no no no i'm no it's all good i'm just
saying you're painting
yeah you are you're crazy i mean that's
everyone knows that
jesus oh you pulled this a lot by the
way you said he's a psychopath i have 24
hours of security now
how many how many people are you going
to blame having 24 cents there's a lot
of people throughout
man [ __ ] this guy i've got 24 hours
security now
hannah i've got 24 hour security [ __ ]
this stalker i've got 24-hour security
i did tell them don't let him in i mean
that was part of it i mean there was
just a lot because you know
wait can i tell you this is tea or do
you want to keep going with this is that
actual tea that i wasn't going to say
but the point is that i didn't respond i
do want to hear about that
but i was like the point is that i'm not
going to respond i'm going to talk to
moses first because you said
he's talking to underage girls and he's
talking to your fans so i was like so he
was like no i'm not doing that
trish is crazy he's saying sexually he
didn't say you're crazy but he's like i
didn't do that she's just mad
and so i responded i said hey these are
super serious allegations i talked to
moses about it i just want to make sure
that i'm responsible with this stuff
because
obviously i don't want i don't want to
not have
done my due diligence on this he says
it's not true i'm just tr i just want to
get past this
and then you said and then you said oh
it's all good actually what you said is
he's disgusting i was trying again
another girl came out of the woodwork oh
my god
and then but anyway you guys worked it
out guess what i have his instagram
password i'll show you right now he
doesn't damn me like he like
and then he said that you are ugh i
don't know because we were dating and
like it has events like we weren't
dating but then awesome
he said he broke up with you because you
started like punching him
he's shaking his head no
oh okay you said i could say everything
i did not punch him you said that's why
you broke up with me because i punched
you
i went like this okay and he's frail
but i didn't plan it wasn't can i okay
if you wanna do
fine if you're gonna [ __ ] if you're
leaving this and i'm gonna have to say
the full [ __ ] story
because what happened was is we were
like
upstairs and i took his phone i saw like
other dms to girls
he like tackled not tackled me but like
we went to the floor and so then i like
punched back but i
never punched him i was like hey you
piece of [ __ ] like i wasn't like that
you guys had a tussle
he had bruises so of course he's like oh
my god like look and i was just like i
didn't do it like on purpose i was like
that you know what i mean it was a tough
you guys were fighting over his phone
oh my god well then i took his keys and
so he was trying to get the keys back
but can i say yes how long did we fight
for the keys like
12 hours off and on
basically 12 hours of fighting but i had
him
like i was putting all my weight on it
on the bed like to like not let him get
it cause i'm like okay all my weights on
it he's not gonna be able to get the
keys
and literally we just started like
[ __ ] oh my god
you guys are so crazy how was this and i
was like oh maybe this is the key
because we never did it like that i was
just like bent over like like standing
and i was just like
oh and then he opened his pants down and
we just started [ __ ] and i was like
oh
moses what is wrong with you oh god you
need jesus
the point is obviously and also we
weren't dating i don't know why he said
we
he broke up with me because of that we
weren't no he he said he called it off
after it got
after the tussle i guess it wasn't abuse
oh my god
it wasn't like i punched him and like
you guys i know moses
he's he wouldn't he wouldn't endure that
he wouldn't get back with you i want to
say
i don't i don't want to paint it as like
he's moses is in an abusive relationship
he's a self-sufficiency
just trying to understand what happened
because i've been getting a lot of grief
from you i'm just trying to understand
what's going on because now you guys are
buying a house together
yeah oh my god that's crazy this is
awful this is why i should have done
the podcast because honestly this is the
first episode
well good thing i'm not going to share
anymore we're both not sharing any more
personal details with you
yes he will nope nope all right well so
anyway i feel like we've we've pretty
much
covered enough ground here on the moses
thing but you guys are in a good place
now
no hustling no tussling i have all
access to instagram accounts
foams that's the definition of a good
healthy relationship like i always know
when you guys are texting him like i
always just know
like even before when he was you guys
would text him like what's the tweets
like what are these
i'm like don't [ __ ] respond like it
way early on
yeah freaky i love it i know the group
chat so
i know so much actually the group chat
yeah i know you're about your guys
i know all the group chats that come
through so i'm just saying i know
everything about
i know a lot even about like your i just
know everything about your family and
stuff so
anyways there's nothing to know about my
family i'm just saying i know a lot so
are you trying to like threaten me no i
just know a lot like
you have a big mouth okay maybe i got a
big mouth too but i'm gonna be nice and
just like
nothing about my family okay you're
right
i literally had no insecurity okay
i'm not going to i'm not going to for
moses to say because you know what i
love moses and i [ __ ] respect
like the stuff but you're making private
you're making something in private and
you put it in public he tells me
i'm proud but i'm literally
you're making it sound worse by not
saying what it is because there's
nothing i guess that's what it is and i
told you what happened
no about you knowing something about my
family oh okay i mean no
something bad i'm just saying there's
little things that i know too it's not a
big deal whatever what
so say it i mean it's nothing like it's
not there's no reason to say it but
you're making it sound like it's bad i'm
just saying i know everything so don't
act like oh you have some special
connection with moses like i know more
than you do about everything
like i know everything about everything
i know more about moses than anybody
like i know more about your family than
anybody i know more about historically
than everything
yeah i know about i don't know anything
about my family exactly exactly how do
you know anything about my family my
parents don't even know anything about
themselves
what what is happening why did you turn
this into some weird veiled threat
it's not a threat you're like i know the
truth but you know what that's why i
feel like i actually do like
feel love for you because i feel sorry
for you so i was like okay that makes
sense and now i feel more like
compassion for you so why do you feel
sorry for me i just get it
oh my god she's just making [ __ ] up to
like try to sound tough
i get it i just say what you're saying
they have very similar like upbringings
like i get it
oh about my family i've talked about
them all the time but i just get it
what about how my parents like were not
involved at all in my life
if we're gonna rosh hashanah we
shouldn't talk about this this episode i
talked about this all the time
on the podcast it's not a big secret
that's what you were frank no i don't
whatever what does moses know about my
me and my parents relationships you said
some weird
[ __ ] dude now let's [ __ ] get it out
in the open i love your family i can't
wait to meet them
i literally can't wait you still want to
[ __ ] my dad
no i have a boyfriend all right but i
definitely want to try your mom
she's a horrible chef but i'm pretty
good my sister is good
we'll probably just order out not that
so what's the tea you have
it's an ah you said you had tea yeah
because of
you actually my first thought the real
first initial reason i got the security
which is why
i blame moses so literally our first
like
breakup which is like we weren't like
officially dating but like the first
time we took a break for two weeks or
whatever
um from talking was the day before my
birthday
and literally the next day an israeli
man
shows up to my house with a gun
and okay i didn't know at first first he
shows up oh god i shouldn't say this
he's
basically this is it he's your fan sees
me on the h3 podcast because my friend
was there because it was my birthday so
i had my gate open so people could have
like deliveries come through and stuff
because i knew i was gonna get flowers
and [ __ ] so i was like let me just have
this open
and this is like 12 hours after i told
moses to never talk to me again sort of
thing
all of a sudden an israeli shows up like
like i see him through my camera
what the [ __ ] but didn't always israeli
at the time comes back my friend
now my my best friend is there like
delivering something but also during
covis was like standing back
and the guy comes up again like the guy
was at my door an hour later comes back
again
and my friend was like you know like who
are you blah blah and he's like oh and
he's like how did you know like i just
need to talk to trisha like i'm in love
with her she needs love like she's gonna
die soon like i need to give her love
like
why do you have a gun okay why okay so
then he's i guess he's he said he's
so basically he got cedric got like his
name and number because he was like what
the hell like this is weird he got his
name and number he talked him for a
minute whatever and then he kept calling
my friend
and was like um what's happening what's
happening he goes i saw her on the
bachelorette like she
like i need to love her because yeah
exactly for real yes
he's like h3 like i know them and all
stuff and then he's like then he said he
was like israeli and i was like oh my
god like moses like sent this like
hitman or something
and you guys also hated me so all of a
sudden it's in israel by the way just so
you know he's not my fan the people that
watch our show hate me
well he watches the show so anyways so
he's like i know h3 like he said it like
that like as if it was a person
and he's like i'm israeli and i was in
the israeli
oh he's the same age because i looked
him up he left his real name and number
which was very weird but anyways
um so he's like he goes he's the same
age as like moses in the military i was
like oh this is weird so i really did
think moses like was trying to set me up
to like die
like i thought he like hired a hitman or
whatever and then like because
you always hear that like you like tell
someone i never talk to you again and
then they kill you the next day so then
i was like oh [ __ ]
so then anyways he he left but then my
friend like ordered a pizza to my house
like
my actual friend was like i got you
dominus because i didn't know what to
get you so i had the delivery guy coming
through the big gate
the guy like runs in he's like really
what the [ __ ]
yeah anyway so please come this is the
[ __ ] crazy things arrest him right
i guess books him i don't know the word
wait hold on he ran in with a gun
i like closed the door i caught this was
the second i called 9-1-1 i called in
one it's like the middle of the day
i called i don't know you closed locked
the door what did you get the pizza
no i didn't get the pizza so he was out
there with the pizza guy
i don't know because like literally i
didn't i didn't look at the events i
don't know like what happened but like i
guess
i don't know what happened with them
obviously they both at some point left
but he came back a week later
and this is when moses and i reconnected
because he came back a week later jumped
the fence
oh so i had the security 24 hours for a
week the guy comes back
well he came back that night at two so
so shane and ryan came over to celebrate
my birthday on may 8th
and then right when they left at like 1
30 a.m this guy comes back now at this
point i have the security there because
i was able to get them really quick
um but i it was expensive so i had it
for a week the minute the first day i
don't have security the guy comes back
jumps my fence tries to get him through
the [ __ ] thing
it was so insane and the messages he
kept sending to my friend
was i'm israeli i was in the military i
know h3 like it was all of that and i
was just thinking like
um i'm being set up to be killed and
it's because of you and moses
and elam uh yeah
we did that no what happened with him
was he arrested did he go away what
happened yeah i don't know i should say
this but
this is why i [ __ ] now i have two
security because when one takes a
bathroom break i gotta have like another
one on guard
you know what i mean but um you have a
small army at your apartment
literally for hannah one for the stalker
and moses was awesome in the military
for moses you know just huh yeah what no
oh is security for him or he is this
well you did before he used to work
security which is another like benefit
so um so what happened to the the stock
so they can't they literally booked them
arrested them all stuff like that they
can't
hold them because of covid this was
during may like they literally
like you can like yeah you can try and
kill someone but like we'll let them go
because he came back
at 2 a.m so what about him now is he
still coming to your house well then
like i guess after the
the week he came back the private
detective like called him i guess
because he gave the name a number
um i was like hey latrice alone is like
oh i'm so sorry i didn't know and i
guess he got scared
and called the detective back i was like
oh i sent her some gifts like i don't
want to get arrested because he had a
he had a kid with him oh my god oh my
god that's all right i don't know
anyways
oh that's so sad what the [ __ ] i have
like crazy
i've had like actual i know people are
like i mean i want to say do all people
who do porn get like crazy stalkers i
wonder
so i think that's it because i never
used to get like ever this and i think
because i started doing like only
because even after like the adam 22 like
collab and lena like i
got really weird people and this is
actually another me and moses the time
we broke up and got back together was
because i was in crisis
because the second time we got back
together was like in july
and my security was like hey there's
like people like casing your house but
we didn't like definitely wasn't fans of
mine
and um and then that time too oh well i
don't know if i should say all this but
i mean
at this point like the person got into
my house like when i was taking a shower
ew what wait the crazy guy would that's
been stalking you with this kid
got in your house i think because i
didn't see
i saw crazy i thought i was like
hallucinate yeah it's very it's that's
so
disturbing yeah so anyway i'm sorry
that that's that's it's because of you
that was scary
well i don't accept responsibility if
you're gonna blame me
i'm gonna blame you and bring all of it
but why don't you move
you've gotta move to a more secure spot
that's what we're doing yeah
you guys are gonna get a baller ass
house because you're pretty rich
there's like water slides like they're
freaking oh you've already been looking
at places
you have a good idea of what you want
yeah we know like exactly where to go
and stuff like that but
there's a specific house already or just
an area but definitely the area
are you going to get you should go gated
for sure but double gate
like double gates inside of the gated
like i don't just want like a house to
go yeah
the gated is is awesome i love the gate
yeah my dad lives in a gated and i like
reputed with him so
this feels better so um wait we didn't
even talk about you we can't wrap it up
we didn't even talk about you
well we've got a family issues and your
relationship issues
i think we have to do is he looks like
what no we're trying though
i feel like she is and you guys just
don't no she's not really yeah so i
would tell you she's like so happy
recently like in the podcast she's like
smiling at you and laughing and giggling
and i'm like
is it possible we just have a good
marriage and where when would that work
you didn't say i love you when she left
or kissed her you're
like dude dude we've been married we've
been together for like
god knows like almost let's see we got
married in
2012 so it's been eight years of
marriage we were together for five years
before we we've been together for 12
years
and you can't say i love you i tell i
love you all the time
you didn't say it when she left i wanted
something happens to her and you never
said i love you or what does something
happen to you because she knows
did i see him yes you guys are so funny
because i was awkward when i came here
but you guys are like hella awkward too
so it just makes everything awkward
like you guys aren't like lovey-dovey
all over each other
i don't know what you expect i was just
like sweating like just to me to be like
caressing her all the time
well like normally meanwhile this would
be like even in public we're always all
over each other but this is different
love
new love no
let's keep it to an hour
hour's good because you don't want to
give them too much just enough to keep
them interested
what do you want to talk about next time
you want to talk about yeah and all your
the topic of this episode was really
just you and moses which i think we
really fleshed out
it was a great i think we covered a lot
of ground yeah i think that's done
talking about that
because you just yeah now we just go
home and i have to like punch him again
just kidding no i think we did a really
good job
domestic abuse isn't funny no i agree
and
and moses would not stand for that yeah
and you guys are still together so i'm
not trying to say domestic abuse
you guys [ __ ] afterwards no during
because then he still was pissed and i
still was like
oh one one final okay whatever i talked
about
give me your give me your final thought
i was just saying you know what i was
super impressed about mo this that day i
threw
i threw my keys over i threw his keys
over my
belt my gate you know like the really
tall gate like what like eight foot gate
he just hopped over it really i was like
whoa who is that like i was expecting
him to like whatever but he hopped over
it
and then i tried to stand behind his car
and he almost ran me over but my legs
looked really skinny in his rear view i
don't have that
picture anymore what you're so crazy
because then he got in the car
i just
can i just can i just say in closing
trisha he's my brother-in-law and i wish
him well so i just want to say
all this crazy with the king throwing
the keys in the center
you just gotta you gotta tone it down
you're gonna buy a house with them you
talk about serious stuff
well it's over we gotta tone it down he
wasn't making it like official so i was
like paranoid is like why and then so
now we're official we're good we're
solid with everything's great
and no damning me [ __ ] about him
flirting with underage girls
um i didn't think he was flirting with
underrated you literally said that i
said
you literally no you literally said that
oh my god
but he does he's not and he never did to
our wedding in l.a or israel
or maui we have three i'll come to all
three of them
really sure you guys wouldn't come you
said he's like my family is not going to
come to maui i'm like so it's just gonna
be my family's like yeah and i'll have
the ocean i'll come to maui okay
really you don't think i'd come to maui
why not i mean from israel
yeah they weren't you said ethan and ela
would not come to maui
yes but my family's coming to maui and
you said ethan and nila won't travel
with a baby now no
see you can't leave now we'll leave the
baby with my parents
well you guys are getting married
tomorrow yeah probably soon
yeah whatever who cares i'll go to one
of them
no come on i would love if you came to
all three i don't want to go to i
probably won't go to israel
we might buy a place in israel oh god i
want to hold it down just slow down
slow down or hulan i want to one house
at a time
shout out hulan israel houlon yeah
what the [ __ ] is hulan oh alone you
didn't even get close to saying it right
i was like hulon there moses and ila
are born in a city called alone
all right let's wrap it up
stop oh ali oh my god
wait did you just say you like his dick
i want him gross
oh i know like laylee cat pot like like
my [ __ ]
right ew and she just touched your
crotch
i could see that was gross anyways all
right okay let's wrap it up
this is the first episode of frenemies i
think we lived up to the expectation
we've
resolved what a name i think it
summarizes the relationship though yeah
well that's not the name of the show
it's not friends it's frenemies
okay yeah that's me and dan we're in
front of me that's why
i can't believe he's here is he on
camera are talking or can you hear him
through this one no that's just h3
exclusively for you guys you guys can
keep man
so anyway that's for episode one we'll
be back next week
we film on monday and we post on tuesday
so this so we'll see you guys next
tuesday
uh we'll talk about something new well
there'll be a new topic for us to
explore right
yeah not about me anymore this is not
going to be you i can't wait to look
okay
questions you want to bring a topic yeah
but i feel like we should also talk
about topic topics yeah yeah yeah
podcast like
no we could tell we should totally i
just we had to get this out of the way
okay because everybody was wondering
what the hell is going on maybe we'll
talk about tick tock next time
sure that's exciting tune in for that
keemstar
we could talk about game star whatever
you want love you
watch all my work should we shout it out
promo dramaalert yeah
what up you want to give a shout out to
dramaalert nothing but love
yeah we're all peace and positive yeah
keemstar is the best
all right thank you guys for watching
hope you enjoyed and we'll see you next
week
all right